you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game six
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between Anand and Carlsen going
into this round Carlson takes a three to
two lead over andand and Anand with the
white pieces and this one opens with E
for as was the case in games two and
four of this match and we follow game
four we enter the Royal apes' Berlin
defense and it is here where we now have
an adjustment
instead of castles we now have d3
reinforcing he for not allowing its
capture and now Bishop c5 you cannot win
'if I've keep in mind at the end of it
you're not just winning the pawn back
you are now losing so we won't have that
what we do have is what's quite common
looking to now build in the center with
d4 both sides castle both sides get
there Brooks working reinforcing their
EEP ponds and also vacating the F 1 and
F 8 squares for minor pieces this is a
common maneuver for white with the Queen
Knight and also for black with the
bishop to play to g7 which would watch
over the dark squares this pond will
often like to watch over the f5 square
in order to come back the knight who
could jump into that point so we don't
have those maneuvers just yet we do have
the maneuver on the white side
eventually but first a question of the
bishop white is not going to give up the
bishop pair staying quite active
pointing right at the king and now how
exactly to get out of this pin what
might be tried and maybe quite tempting
is to play h6 and then g5 but you
certainly always have to be wary of some
sacrifice on g5 you just lash out like
this this could be problematic
how exactly get out of this pin and
right around their corner
there could maybe be more pressure being
placed against that night not so easy to
untangle so we'll see exactly how you
can deal with this particular pin
without having to
your pawns like so first is Bishop e6 92
a question is thrown to the bishop will
it keep the knight in a pin or go
elsewhere
keeps the knight in a pin Bishop's come
off the rook is now able to pinpoint a
six and now we're seeing the way that
black will cope with this pin the knight
will be responsible for defending him
and then the Queen will eventually get
off of that diagonal h3 is a flight
square and the knight will also look to
reposition and maybe hit that pinned
piece 97 Knight H to Queenie 7 and
Knight f1 a lot of maneuvering no no
great fireworks happening in this game
no haymakers being thrown just yet a lot
of improvements being made for the
pieces getting them to better positions
and with this last move there should be
six initially I thought it was two maybe
free up the C pawn sometimes you'll see
that out of this opening but I believe
that that is simply bad here there would
at the very least be a good reply in
that of c4 keep in mind what this
particular move would do it would weaken
d5 and this night you could be sure
would not be long off from hopping to
that square so what is the intention if
the if it's not to get the C pawn
involved well this is a quite common
idea right here this is a quite common
idea for white to play b4 and clamp down
on the black position get the the one
doubled pawn rolling so maybe at least
this pond can move one day it's really
aimed at trying to clamp down on the a6
pawn and so black wants to be in a
position to eliminate what could be
potentially a target by playing a5 so
now the bishops there at least just
support that idea
93 Queen e6 finally off of the diagonal
b4 comes and sure enough we have black
making sure they get rid of their
potential liability on the a file
those pawns are exchanged and why not
try to exchanging not so well-placed
night on h2 for one that is perfectly
central on f6 that's the idea and don't
blink because before you know it we now
have all minor pieces off the board and
we're stripped to a completely heavy
endgame with just just the major pieces
rooks and Queens one quick point to make
is that this move might have been
tempting but be mindful of f2 Queen or
Bishop can snip that pun so instead it's
queen g4 both sides now have their rooks
in direct contact with one another we do
have some structural defect here on the
white side but this has all the makings
of a draw so what exactly to do with the
rook how exactly to improve because
right here we have tension between the
rooks but neither side really does well
to take the rook because it would help
out the other two then have complete
control over the a file so Queen East 7
King if you're to make a tucking in type
of move as black King h7 keep in mind
what it would be allowing right King h7
Queen d7 is very disruptive hitting the
rook upon the one on b5 and eventually
you could see that the a file will also
be taken over by white by putting
pressure on the a8 square so you
definitely don't allow that Queen e7 is
there to defend rook f1 why not white is
perfect here having rook on an open file
and a half open file and what exactly is
this rook doing on e8 not really a whole
lot c5 is played looking to mix it up a
little bit in the center looking to play
c4 and strike at d3 King h2 tucking
tucks the King in a little bit and c4
does get play
and as the reply we have d4 if you
capture the pond notice what is
happening with that structural change
you know as white you would now have
double isolated ponds that's not a great
thing and the other detail well now b2
would be accessible to the black pieces
are more accessible to the black pieces
so we don't have this capture it is d4
and with that black it seems can be
winning upon on e4 after this capture
there's clearly a couple pieces that
will be brought to life and then efore
can fall in a blink but we don't have
that we have first carlson giving up
control over the a file and now Queen to
b7
this was this was surprising to me I
thought that the follow up would have
been to capture on d4 but why wasn't
that played isn't black just winning
upon well not so fast because sure you
went upon but it's very temporary at the
end of it a check is thrown in and the
rook sneaks right behind the pond and
will win the pond there's no way to
defend it and at the end of it the rook
remains very active defense and maybe
even one of these two pawns would fall
so not the direction to go in the white
rook would be perfect
defending the base point and still
staying active after grabbing the pawn
on b5 so that's not the line we go down
the road we see instead after giving up
control the a file the Queen now plays
to b7
well what's the idea behind this well it
is to take now with the pun and then
take with the rook keeping more pieces
on the board it's a different story
if the Queen's are on the board still if
it's just the rooks it's certainly
looking more Josh so Queen to b7 notice
she is also watching over potential
entry points by the rook
and again functioning pointing right at
that efore point rook d1 is they're very
nice and if this pawn is taken the rook
simply recaptures and is right there to
defend e4 Queen c7 or queen c6 we have a
couple Queen moves thrown in the main
thing here is that white needs to watch
over efore black needs to watch over d6
and not too much change will occur at
this point with regard to the pawn
structure so let's see how things
progress first the rook takes up a nice
post on e5 Queen c7 a lot of shuffling
here and we don't really see too too
much for a little bit these last handful
of moves by Black improved the King
position ever so slightly that's the
best that black can really do with the
King position and during the game I must
admit I thought that if f5 wasn't going
to be played I didn't see any life to
this position whatsoever but we end up
seeing some pawns being captured and
this structure does change in some way
so King g7 Queen f3 the rook drops back
and now Queen to g3 basically saying go
ahead take my pun and enter a position
where you could be up upon and I see a
way that I can defend that's essentially
what's going on here because the
following secant sequence of moves will
we'll show that much where we are now
going to enter a position where Carlsen
is up upon but has a very passive rook
versus a white rook which is very past
which versus a white rook which is very
active so that's what we see rook takes
on e queen takes D and now rook takes
III the Queen's come off rook d5 rook to
b7 what do we have black is up upon but
this rook is very very active I do want
to point out one
variation here where you'll know if
black captures on d6 here and then
captures on e3 note that there is look
to d5 and now white is simply ready to
win this pun there could then be b4 and
after its capture rip to b3 these ponds
will now be exchanged and we're
certainly entering what is likely to be
a drawn position similar to what we saw
in game 4
where Anand had the white pieces and it
would turn out to be 2 vs 1 in favor of
Carlsen but with still the rooks on the
board
a pair of rooks on the board it was a
very much so holdable position and Anand
was able to draw that we will have a
similar thing going on here it may be a
little bit more difficult but if we do
enter a position where it's a 3 to 2
that is still looking like it's a drawn
position we could we could have
something like this where the rook ends
up coming over the white there the Kings
get involved eventually we could have
all of these pawns being exchanged and
what we will eventually have here is yet
again something like this three versus
two this is I think what white is
looking for to exchange the pawns so
that we just have pawns on one side of
the board now how are things a little
bit different here when you don't take
well by taking on e3 first and allowing
the rook to have to be on e7
in response to rook d5 now you could at
least defend the pawn with rook to b7 in
the previous position that I just showed
the rook would have been on III and
would not be in this position to defend
b5 after white playing the rook to d5
rook to be seven super passive and this
rook is super active cutting now off the
King again white down upon but very very
active rook not allowing now the black
King to contribute not allowing the
black King to get towards the center so
easily f6 first h5 is played decent
amount of time was spent on that one
about 12 minutes this is aimed at
disrupting the pawn structure looking to
strike at the center and induce some
weaknesses and sure enough we do see
that anon gives up yet another pawn in
order to smash open this pawn structure
so now white is down to pawns but still
with a very active rook and now this is
a very ugly a very messy black pawn
structure it seems like one of these
three pawns will fall soon enough
rook to d5 pin points h5 White King gets
involved rip to b6 rook to c5 rook to c5
is really saying you know what if you
ever think about playing your pawn to b4
I'm gonna take c4 right away and what's
also worth noting is that instead of
let's say rook to b6 let's just say b4
is played the follow up would be the RIP
to play to c5 takes takes at the end of
it you cannot defend c4 white will be
winning that pond soon enough
so we instead have rook to b6 we're up
to c5 f5 king h4 and now we have well
black gives us up this pun in exchange
for what exactly
rook activity looking to now give some
checks to the white king and in doing so
is allowing the black King to inch
closer in into the white position so the
pawn is picked up a check is thrown in
the White King is inconvenienced the
black king is making a little bit of
progress but really is it going to be
enough the rook is dropping back to
maybe give some check
to the black King we have first h4 being
played so that when there is a check
being played the King can inch over just
right there on the H file tucked in
nicely right behind his pawns there are
no more successful checks if this H pawn
weren't around maybe this is easier for
white right maybe this is a very very
important pot although doubled rook to
FA his defense is hitting the pawn it is
now going to be defended or thrip to f4
and maybe there are also ideas of
playing to f1 inconveniencing the King
forcing him to go to h2 as otherwise it
would be mate on each one
rook to c8 rook g4 basically just
keeping pressure on the c4 pawn dropping
this pawn would mean that white would
have something very valuable connected
passed pawns rook to f8 the roof gives a
check King to g5 rook to g8 and now
we're exactly to go with the king if
King to f6 keep in mind if the rook is
taken
the material is balanced but this is a
completely lost position for white this
pawn negates these two because of the
grip on the b3 square and it's basically
two versus one game over white will end
up losing this one so you can't exchange
rooks and that is if King to f6 is even
played you wouldn't see Brooke takes
rook and if you're planning to f4 well
that means you're going to drop this
pawn here and what does white then have
connected passed pawns that almost
certainly needs to be avoided but it's
not avoided King to f4 was still played
surprisingly enough and that means that
this pawn is going to fall so was this
there was this a mistake well not so
fast these ponds while they remain
connected are a long way off from posing
a threat to the black side and so why
exactly was this
giving up anon goes right for it has
there been a mistake
King III the pond has picked up the
white rook is active and now these pawns
are ready to roll so how does black
proceed well its first f4 and the idea
here is that now that the rook is
defended h3 is available there's a lot
of this to even have gotten into this
position to inject this life into the
position was very creative on blacks
part is it enough however these are very
almost in all cases these connected
passed pawns are extremely valuable but
keep in mind the strong placement of the
black king and the not-so-great position
of the White King so what is f4 doing
again it is watching over the rook so
that h3 can be played threatening the
pond and after it is captured what has
changed well the F pawn now becomes
passed in just three steps away from its
dream Square on f1 so f4 it is rook to
a4 and this is a big slip and it
certainly may be easy to go wrong here
rook to a4 is played you do have to
still be very on top of your game and
calculate very well rook to a4 the idea
behind this is to well Anand is
anticipating this move this is clear and
the idea will be to try and give these
types of checks to the black king and so
this involved get this involves getting
the B and C pawns on the fourth rank
which allows the rook to be pivoting on
the a1 a2 and a3 squares to keep the
king in check but that is a step in the
wrong direction
b4 would have been better and let's go
down this line for a moment and see how
white could have proceeded here and
maybe this would have been better after
that exchange
the rook is now dropping back and now
this pawn is ready to roll but the white
rook is also there to keep the king in
check
right with rook to e7 and force it rook
to e7 or rook to d7
for example if black is pushing you
could give a check what are you going to
do here you can keep giving a check if
this pawn has ever taken now he's too
far away from defending this pawn and we
could end up having a completely dead
drawn position the other attempt might
be to after give a check to do something
like this get the King to f1 but black
is soon reminded that white also has a
passed pawn it's not so clear how
exactly to get this King out of the F
file so that this pond could advance
successfully this would have been a
better approach by white to say the
least instead of playing the rook to a4
on this move 60 move 60 enters that new
time control but time in this game was
never a factor plenty of time at this
point for both sides so rookie 4 was
played and sure enough it is h3 giving
up the pawn in order to grant this one a
free run to the f1 square and not too
long ago it was black who was up to
pawns and now all of a sudden is black
who is down upon but this pawn is very
dangerous on f4 how to stop it
rook g6 gets out of the way so the fun
the this Ponk it finally March c4 like I
said these ideas here these next moves
are made so that it allows the rook to
be giving check a lat and trying for a
lateral defense to kick the King around
f3 rook check King e to b4 and now here
we have it many checks can be thrown
into the King f2 continuing to march and
now we have rook
- King f3 and before I go any further
there was actually an interesting move
that could have been played at this
moment here after a nun's b4 there could
be Czech and this is an interesting
sequence of moves to give another check
on g1 and then you're able to advance
with check and promote to a queen next
so an interesting motif to be aware of
something that I certainly did not see
to give a check another check and then
advance to Queen we did not have that
however after b4 we had f2 this is
another approach the rook gives a check
King to f3 is there a way to get out of
a check there is king to f4 and now what
the pawn is ready to promote rook to e8
don't promote so fast that Queen will be
one right back
so it is first rook g1 and at this point
Anand resigns this is game over there's
no way to save this you can give a check
and the king can play here you could try
to advance with b5 but now comes the
Queen you need to give up your rope and
these puns are not fast enough they get
tracked down right away after something
like this they are frozen with the rook
on c5 and one of them will be one next
in not long after the other so what an
interesting game really pulling what
looked to being a drawn position was
really converted very nicely into a win
here by Carlsen in this game 6 and
needless to say this puts a great deal
of pressure on Anand who is now trailing
4 points to 2 in 4 points to 2 in favor
of Carlsen at this point right here
tomorrow is a rest
and well we will see what takes place
next it's certainly going to be a very
difficult road ahead in order to
overcome this deficit in the match again
Carlson is now leading with this second
consecutive win with the black pieces 4
2 2 we will see what happens in round 7
of this 2013 World Chess Championship so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye
[Music]